what's your what's your favorite uh
like live streaming meme
or like words that they use because
livestream has its own lingo
that's right let me think
let me think
i don't think i've ever seen cali throw
out like the kw or like i can't pog or
anything yeah you don't kick w you don't
sam yeah that's because she's not on
twitch
are you able to say the word pog or kick
w without no i
can't
you can't you can't give out like a
monkey s every now and then i know i'm
pretty cringe here and there but that's
just a little it's a little too much i
think i might i might collapse into
myself like a black hole
i can't do it man
so that's all you're gonna get from me
because somebody's been sending me pepe
hands
recently and um
yeah
it stays in my mind um is there a meme
you like to see pop up ah let's see
um
let me think let me think
i have to think really carefully about
how i answer this one because every
conversation every question you ask is
me i do want to know what people's
tastes and memes are so i can kind of
gauge that level of interest we don't do
a lot of we don't do a lot of memes in
my chat i feel like you know there's
youtubers versus twitch streamers right
yeah it's it's kind it's hard because i
feel like it depends on the chat right
i'm certainly not like for example it's
not that everyone in holo ian's chats
are like averse to memes no no it's just
the crowd that i've attracted i think
isn't super hardcore and we still we
still have a few yeah sometimes i'll go
to uh youtubers stream and i'll watch it
and i'll just like not understand it and
they'll be like oh my god they said
banana it's the thing it's the thing of
the year joke and i'm like what
applies for like every youtuber no no it
doesn't i don't know what twitch at
least i think i feel like i haven't seen
that i felt that applies to me in twitch
honestly
no some of the dean jokes yeah the in
jokes yeah yeah yeah just because i
don't spend enough time watching twitch
streams i don't know maybe yeah maybe
i'm just talking about i feel like
yeah i feel that with twitch is like
multiple ways it's like it starts off
with a twitch reference that is specific
to twitch and then that evolves into an
intro so it's like multiple layers that
you have to understand whereas on
youtube there isn't really like specific
lingo i guess i don't know with hololive
it's i think all the memes that come
from the subreddit i assume right yeah
that's right there are a lot of things
popping off there i think for sure but i
mean it's the same with trash days right
like all of the memes come from
that's true that is true from somewhere
that's for sure but i mean that's what
we need reddit for just just the memes
yeah yeah keep up to date yeah just keep
up to date with all the memes right
i mean i guess i guess occasionally when
i it's just little things it's not
necessarily just words being spammed in
chat but rather rather things that i do
or make a habit of for example my intro
and outro a lot of times when i start
the stream uh i'll turn up the reverb
and the echo and i'll just say
and then everyone in the chat just says
go or they they use the emote
that's about it hi callie how are you
hey that's it that's about it and then
at the end everyone says peace turn up
the reverb turn up the echo piece and
everyone spams peace in the chat you
know but it's not it's not just like
word after word that's the same kind of
thing not a lot of you know emotes of
course you know you pull out the glow
sticks and the music emote for them for
the live show
that's about the extent of where it goes
to i think now for others in en i can
see it being kind of different you know
they've all got their own personal like
inside jokes and words people like to
say in chat but people get people get
frustrated about that sometimes because
not everybody is a big fan of the
the the same
memes being used
there's a lot of fighting yeah it also
makes it difficult sometimes for newer
people to come in if it's just all in
jokes right yeah it's important to
maintain the balance of a chat shut the
[ __ ] up
because you also don't want to be that
guy that's like um what does this mean
chad
like
yeah there's that pressure as well so
yeah exactly i guess the closest thing
we ever got was
um
you guys know um it's not adam sandler
yeah of course
[Laughter]
anyway
um is that is that just the way you said
that is that like a underground yeah
yeah yeah
this underground new you said youtube
was like an avant garde yeah musical
artist that would never hurt you just
please let me go did you guys know this
guy called uh nicholas cage
um do you know barack obama
so where is this going i mean he just he
just has become like a prominent figure
in like the lore same with the shrek
it's just it's stuff like this
like new people getting into the stream
would maybe get confused so how is adam
sandler playing a part um
he's just always kind of been there like
his spirit it's like hard what you know
he's still he's still doing well
a long time ago there was an event where
that we all we all it's we canonically
we erased it from our brains and i've
been having trouble
remembering it right um and um there was
the existence of of an emote i believe i
can't remember what it looks like and i
don't remember what we called it but i
know old adam was involved and we
banished it uh from the chat we had like
a burning ceremony and everything um
is this like your mandela effect in
motion or something like that
we get a little crazy stuff so i
understand i'm missing so many like
parts of the context of this story we've
jumped right to the exile
how did we get to the exile how did it
even begin i mean i was just kind of
like listen when when i was young baby
reaper um mama mori often put ol adam on
the screen um when she went off to work
and i'd watch ole adam back then just me
just me just just
[Applause]
and of course it came up again in chat
people were like oh what movies do you
like and i was like if you guys see the
happy gilmore and they're like i love
happy young lawyers
actually i do think that that's what
what are your favorite adam sandler
movies mr deeds i love mr dudes
my favorite scene is like hitting his
foot yeah and his foot's like black from
the uh the frostbite yeah
that's right i i heard my first curse
words from that movie i don't remember
that i've seen the movie
i've seen i think 50 first dates that's
like actually like a good one yeah i
think that's a good one and uh
i think click's my favorite that's a
pretty good one too management oh sydney
showed me wedding singer the other day
because i was talking about adam sandler
yeah what were you talking about
i can't remember
why was i talking about adam son
adam just creeps into everyone why was i
talking about adam sandler again
all right she's in another room right
now i mean uh what was i gonna say a
good old girl adam he's just he's become
like a presence and it's hard to explain
why but but he just he just creeped in
have you guys seen uncut gems it's
amazing i haven't i've been trying to
get these guys to watch it it's such a
good movie i remember you talking about
it he's so good it's like he's actually
acting like
he's actually trying my movie list is
like my to watch anime animated watch
list which is like yeah i'll watch it
someday and then um they're all movies
i've heard of but i'm just like yeah
i'll get to it eventually i'll watch it
it's good yeah well what gets me now is
like sometimes memes just get me want to
uh just get me like the urge to watch
certain movies now like megamind memes
have been like coming up more recently
and i'm just like i should actually
watch that movie i have not watched it
it's really good i've heard it's like
really ahead of his time
yeah and just seeing the memes like i
saw the memes and i'm just like let me
watch a few clips and i'm like oh this
is maybe i should like sit down and
watch this maybe i'll do that tonight
actually no i'm thinking about watching
i'll watch megamind do you also have to
be in the right mindset to watch that
it's actually mind gone
it's
like dreamworks and that kind of stuff
that's supposed to be the type of genre
that does so well because you can watch
it yeah that's right but like sometimes
you know when you watch like a show or
something that people have been talking
about you and you just watch it megamind
is not just to keep up with playing
masterpiece you don't need to pay
attention just watch it
i want to pay attention to the [ __ ] i
watch connor
i i want to pay attention to it
there is a genre of entertainment that
does very well because you don't need to
pay attention it's the brain dead
entertainment brain dead yeah
even in the brain dead stuff i like to
pay attention just because when you're
making thumbnails
yeah exactly stuff like that stuff that
you can i think that was what youtube
videos for i thought that was was what
trash chase was for you know that's
that's the brain dead content
if you've got subtitles though it's kind
of a little harder
it's youtube's most brain dead podcast
because like sometimes sometimes you put
on a youtube video right sometimes you
put it on like the second monitor and
then it starts and you're like oh oh oh
this is some main monitor [ __ ] oh oh
okay anything like you switch it you
have to like swap it over to the main
monitor you're like oh okay this is this
is
that's that's how you know it's top tier
content when it's not on your second
monitor it's on your main monitor man i
get that i get that
that to me is just like every movie i
can't have a movie on in the background
right now i can't do that either i can
do that yeah i know you can can you do
that
ah you know it's tough these days
because i actually don't really consume
a lot of media sadly enough because
you're streaming nine hours a day every
day and i have this i have an issue
where if i really get into a series i
have to finish it in one go okay like um
i was reading a manga that i got into
the other night it's been out for a long
time
it's actually kind of it's not a super
new one it's called what was it um i
believe in japanese uh imo
oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah i read it
yeah i watched the netflix show i
watched all of it i was like this is
pretty good and so i just had to figure
out what the ending was and so i read
the whole manga from start to finish in
one day and i was like i could have done
a lot of other stuff but i had to keep
reading it was it worth it yeah it was
good i liked it um i thought the ending
was okay it was fine um but i thought
like the writing and like the the
emotional like writing was it gets a
little much sometimes like a little edgy
but overall i thought it was very well
done so i recommend it i think that's
just like most survival hormones yeah
yeah it's just it's like it's just like
a little touch of too edgy by the way
this is not because of squid game that
i've been getting into like kaiji and
stuff like that i liked kaiji and and
you liked kaiju before it was cool
but like i've been into like death game
stuff like before squid gameplay
just death game manga and anime are
definitely definitely like something
like guilty pleasures oh yeah because
there are some i think in terms of like
the tier of like well-written death
games i think squid game is like on the
better on the side with like the better
written ones even though it is a bit
edgy sometimes but sometimes you just
like read something that's just pure
edge and it just for some reason it's
just
i don't know man it's like junk food for
me i can name about ten yeah yeah
a lot of them do feel quite samey after
a while though yeah they're just like oh
okay you start to be able to predict
things the way the games are gonna go
it's because they're all influenced by
each other yeah so it's like there's
only so much you can do until someone is
like no let me try something else yeah